[Music]
it's saturday night in a borough of
greater manchester
using hidden cameras we're investigating
if pubs and bars are following covid 19
guidance
and collecting customer details for
contact tracing gonna
go outside remember this is an area
where kobit 19 cases have gone up
and new lockdown restrictions have been
put in
in the first venue we visited we weren't
asked for our details
so we asked when leaving
do i need to leave a number or anything
don't worry you're kind of walking you
can't afford to well you're only in five
minutes normally i say 15 minutes or
this isn't what the guidance says all
right cheers
but we headed to the next venue
it's very difficult to keep apart from
people isn't it
again we weren't asked for our details
and saw no other customer being asked
for theirs
everybody were licensed in and the
police and everything i never said
some square down
we tried again as we left
in fact out of the 10 venues we visited
only one proactively asked us for
details
ironically it was the one where social
distancing was hardest
distance you don't feel worried
if he wants to get here it will get you
if it doesn't
it was so busy here we didn't feel safe
and quickly left
we shared that and our footage with the
mayor of greater manchester
it's a situation that we can't we can't
just sort of turn a blind eye to we
won't turn a blind eye to it we're
grateful to you for
uh for bringing this footage to us and i
think it's more than a greater
manchester problem i think this is the
position
all around the country what is the
industry going to do the industry's made
a lot of calls on
government and on policy makers in
recent times they have got to get their
own
houses in order the british beer and pub
association told us in their opinion the
majority of venues are complying but
local authority leaders say that our
report raises serious questions about
enforcing these guidelines
because they are just at their
guidelines they're not mandatory
and they're not enforceable by law
scotland is changing that this weekend
council leaders in england want
westminster to do the same
give us the powers necessary to go in
and
close or take action against those
businesses
who aren't following the guidance
because ultimately this is about trying
to prevent
a second wave and yet the council
probably have greater powers to shut
down the premises if there's an
infestation of rats versus if a premises
isn't
following covert 19 guidelines i think
that's exactly the point
the government has said contact tracing
will help life get
safely back to normal
for it to work properly authorities say
this
has to stop caterina for toxic sky news
greater manchester